so we just finished hopefully getting
intuition for why
you know my initial pressure times my
initial volume divided by my initial
temperature is going to equal you know
if i change the volume or the pressure
or the temperature or some combination
of all of them is going to equal my new
pressure times my new volume
divided by my new temperature and and
once again just remember all of this is
you know pressure times volume is uh
proportional to the amount of kinetic
energy in the system
why and and uh
and temperature is proportional to the
amount of kinetic energy per molecule so
if we don't change the number of
molecules
the the the amount and since by
conservation of energy the amount of
kinetic energy isn't going to change
unless we you know do some work or get
some potential energy or something
these quantities this relationship won't
change and watch the last video and
hopefully you'll get some intuition if
if it's still confusing i'll make
another video for you guys now before i
apply this
before i apply this equation which which
is really this is going to get you
pretty far in thermodynamics just
knowing this and even more just having
the intuition of what it means
i want to clarify something about
temperature so there's a lot of
different ways to measure temperature
you know we we know that in fahrenheit
what's freezing of water it's 32 degrees
fahrenheit is freezing
well that's also
zero degrees
celsius right and actually that's how
the celsius scale was determined they
said okay where does water freeze zero
and then where does water boil 100
degrees
celsius is boiling and that's that's how
they they rated it and of course you
could be colder than the freezing of
water and you'd have to go negative in
that situation fahrenheit i'm actually
not sure how far i i need to look that
up in wikipedia or that might be
something for you to do and and tell me
how how it came out
you know i think boiling of water in
fahrenheit's 212 degrees so it's a
little arbitrary i think fahrenheit
might be somehow related to
human body temperature but i'm just
guessing but anyway you can have
different scales in this situation
and they were all kind of a bit
arbitrary when they were designed kind
of to just
have some type of relative to scale you
know you could say well when things are
boiling they're definitely hotter they
have a higher temperature than when
things are freezing
but it's not clear to say that it has
that you know you have
well you can't divide 100 by zero but if
something is one degree
is it necessarily the case that
something that is 100 degrees celsius
is a hundred times hotter or has a
hundred times the kinetic energy well
actually we'll see that no it's actually
not the case you don't have 100 times
the kinetic energy so this is a bit of
an arbitrary scale
so
the actual interval might you know the
interval's arbitrary you could pick the
one degree as being one hundredth of the
distance between zero and 100 but where
you start at least in the celsius scale
is a bit arbitrary they pick the
freezing of water
so later on people figured out that
there is an absolute point to start at
and that absolute point to start at is
the temperature at which a molecule or
an atom has absolutely no
kinetic energy because we said we said
temperature
is equal to
you know the average kinetic energy
of the system
or the total kinetic energy of the
system divided by the number of
molecules or we could say the average
kinetic energy per molecule
right so the only way to really say that
the temperature is zero
is if and this is proportional i should
say it's proportional because the
temperature
scales are still a little bit arbitrary
it's proportional it's not exactly it's
related to but the only way to get to a
temperature of zero should be when the
kinetic energy of each and every
molecule is zero or the average so
they're not they're not moving they're
not vibrating they're not even blinking
these molecules are stationary
and the point at which that occurs is
called absolute zero
absolute
zero
and that actually occurs
absolute zero and that's also called
zero kelvin
zero kelvin and that is the same thing
is minus
273 degrees celsius so nowhere in the
universe at least that i'm aware of
it
is it colder than minus
273 degrees celsius at that temperature
nothing moves even at the atomic scale i
mean i'm talking the electrons collapse
into the nucleus i mean nothing
everything is completely completely
stationary at zero kelvin and it's it's
a it's a theoretical absolute limit
people and maybe we'll do a bunch of
videos on how you can get close to that
but in laboratory environments or maybe
in deep space it gets really really
close to this but um i'm not
i'm not sure i'm pretty sure and nowhere
in the universe is do we have absolutely
zero
kelvin um at least in any place where we
actually have particles
but i might be wrong there but we that's
a little bit out of the scope of of what
we're talking about so anyway
so
the true way to measure temperature is
kelvin and then when you're measuring in
kelvin if i say
i have something that is 1
kelvin
versus something that is 5 kelvin
since we kind of nail down the bottom at
a point at which we really do not have
kinetic energy i can
i can make the statement that this has
five times the energy of this something
that's at five kelvin versus welcome one
kelvin so that whole long explanation
about kelvin that's just to make the
point that whenever we use this formula
or really any formula in thermodynamics
and involve temperature
we should convert to kelvin unless we're
just doing change in temperature then
you could you could probably keep it
celsius but when you're doing
proportionality or using it multiplying
or dividing by temperature you have to
use kelvin and hopefully i made a little
bit clearer of why that is
so let's do an example
so let's let me
let me erase and you'd be surprised how
far this takes you and really the main
trick is just to remember to convert
things to kelvin that's what that's
that's the number one reason why people
miss questions on thermodynamics exams
is that they didn't convert to kelvin
so i'm going to get a problem this
problem and this is very typical of most
of what you'll see this is from the
barons ap physics b on page 226 and it
says
let me see
a confined gas is a temperature of 27
degrees so its initial
initial temperature is 27
degrees celsius
when it has a pressure and volume so its
pressure
its pressure is 1000
pascals or newtons per meter
squared
and
the volume
volume
is 30
meters cubed i think in one of the
earlier videos i think i said newton's
per meter cube now it's newton's per
meter squared i just want to make sure i
didn't confuse people previously so
that's the initial volume
and then it says the volume is decreased
so then we we go to this state
where my new volume
is going to be
20 meters
cubed
the new temperature
it's it's increased so the new
temperature is now 50 degrees celsius
and they want to know
they want to know what is my new
pressure
so before we just substitute into the
equation and solve for the new pressure
remember if they gave it to you in
celsius convert to kelvins and if they
gave it to you in fahrenheit which they
seldom do then convert into celsius and
then convert it into uh kelvin
well we we already know that you know 0
kelvin is equal to 273
sorry minus 273 celsius or another way
you could say it is x kelvin
kelvin
x kelvin is equal to
well essentially whatever
degree you get in celsius you just add
273 to it does that make sense because
think of it this way
zero cal
if you're at zero degrees celsius
if you're zero degrees celsius you're at
you're already at two you're 273 degrees
above zero kelvin right
think about that
hopefully that makes sense maybe you
want to draw a number line just to make
sure so whatever celsius degree you have
just add 273 to it and you'll get kelvin
so this is equal to what this is equal
to let me do it in in a new color
at 273 to 27 degrees celsius that's 300
kelvin
and then 50 degrees celsius is what at
273 to it
so 50 plus 273
is 3
23
right
so now we can substitute into this
formula so p1
1000
1000
pascals times v1 times 30
divided by the first temperature
remember to do in kelvins 300 is equal
to p2 that we don't know what that is p2
times v1 sorry times v2 this should be a
2 here times v2 times 20
divided by our new temperature 323.
let's see we could simplify this we
could take two zeros off of here take
two zeros off of here
and then we could take a
three out of here and take a
three out of here and we're left with a
hundred
right this is equal to hundred right
that's three thousand divided by
um
i'm sorry that's thirty thousand divided
by three hundred and so that's a hundred
on the left hand side so we have a
hundred
is equal to p times twenty
over three twenty three
and then let me do it up here i'm
running out of time
and so if i were to just solve for it
323
times 100
equals
divided by 20
equal so my new pressure is 16 15
16
15 pascals and i just solved this
equation and the hard part was
converting to kelvin see in the next
video